[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum hey up there how's it
going I'm for those people that sing on
audio I'm waving to the wide shot it's
just me and a wide shot and there's a
close-up of me if you're watching on
YouTube another week I finally went
grocery shopping again it was a good ten
days or more
I've been quarantine for 22 days now so
alright big deal just trying to keep
safe but today I did go to the grocery
store I wore masks and on the way home I
drove by a couple friend's house I
stayed in the truck was far away and I
just called them said step outside wave
to them so I might send a video out
there of just friends waving from a
hundred yards away just wanted some some
kind of you know I some celebrity
friends around here some friends that
aren't celebrities and I just I just
waved at them I did a drive-by what are
you doing tweet me Instagram me what are
you doing during the quarantine do you
have a family are you alone like me are
you are you playing some music or what
kind of music you listening to you right
now I kind of sound like a DJ right now
99.5 w KD q hey fans of inside of you or
first time listeners we listen to out
their own yeah what's getting you going
what are you eating what are you cooking
are you cooking out there make sure you
exercise I'm not gonna tell you what to
do but I find that when I do exercise I
feel a lot better I try to fill my days
up with things you know walks playing
with the dogs it's funny how much better
you feel when you just write down from
one to two I'll play with the dogs from
two to three I'll cut my finger open
like I did that's why I have a band-aid
and anyone so hey we got a great episode
those of you who didn't get a chance to
listen to Nick Swardson boy that was a
good one if very funny comedian hangs
with you know the Sandler gangs and all
the Sandler movies really funny funny
guy and if you haven't listened to him
make sure you watch it on YouTube or
I'll listen
um and subscribe please - inside of you
on the YouTube and you know it's really
helped them trying to grow and it's
tough because people commuting they're
not commuting as much people are not
working as much so but I appreciate the
support I appreciate my patrons out
there you know who you are and I'll say
your names of course some of you out on
the outro
you know the handles all that stuff
inside of you podcasts on Twitter and
Instagram and Facebook and spread the
word you know that's how it works it's
word of mouth if you really are liking
it diggin it it's helping you got great
guests one of which today is uh this guy
you know it this is the second time he's
come on this is the first time we we did
the interview with so you could watch it
you know we film them now and it's
pretty great ryan taya's my editor
engineer he really does such a superb
job in the editing room and um getting
the goods Rooker is a tough type tough
type yeah I said it I've known him for a
long time he's a friend a lot of great
stories it's hard to get him serious but
when he does it's uh you know you could
see it he's trying to hold back but you
know you know there's something there
there's a lot of history behind his eyes
and great actor great intensity just
very forthcoming honest and I loved
having him so just a reminder before we
go to Michael Rooker you know I'm trying
to do this live podcast with Zack Levi
that might might not happen I don't know
it's July 2nd at the north door
back-to-back shows July 2nd Austin Texas
conventions guys we'll just see what
happens down the road you know you could
always listen to left on Laurel the band
my band playing you could listen to it
for free all over streaming tell me what
you think the online store is still open
didn't close online inside of you online
store but seriously you know tweet me
Instagram me I'm doing a lot of these
Instagram live so if you're listening
and you haven't got a chance it's great
it's kind of like a sing-along people
throw songs at me and I've never heard
or I know I've heard
I've never played before and I just I
have a guitar and I looked them up and I
put chords and I just try to play it off
the cuff and sometimes it's [ __ ]
then sometimes it's great and people are
really diggin I bring people on the
video in the Instagram lives it's fun
also if you're a really big fan of the
podcast join patreon if you want extra
footage bonus footage questions with me
inside of me videos to you messages to
you some tears get merch packages every
few months you get to ask questions to
the guests it's a lot of fun it's
community I now do a YouTube patreon I
did it last week and boy it was a
success we had a lot of fun all my
patrons got on there and we did it was
just us so feel free to do that and most
importantly forget everything I said if
you want and help your fellow human
being by going you know supporting the
Ronald McDonald House I just did her
dinner with my friend Daisy biota
haenyeo she and I am sponsored to dinner
at the Ronald McDonald House for all the
families if you don't know what ramadan
house is imagine these are children kids
babies that are suffering from many
different things cancers leukemias just
different things and Ron McDonald House
they housed the families while their
child is going through treatment so it's
a pretty amazing place and they need
your help the families need food and
they're always looking for a sponsor of
a dinner you can get it dinner anything
for 250 bucks so if you have 25 friends
10 bucks each them I try to do as many
as I can also echoes of Hope foster
youth is a great charity and food on
foot the homeless are really suffering
you think it's it's tough being homeless
before this like it could be any tougher
and it just got tougher so foot food on
foot org ask for my friend Rob Danson
tell him Michael Rosenbaum sent you
anyway you know it's always nice to help
it always feels good you know there's a
great thing that happened I'll say one
more thing on the Instagram live I don't
know if I told you this story but I
randomly select people in scope and they
come up on the video and they know it's
half a screen of the person randoms and
me and so I just said oh let's go with
Megan Clifford and she goes hey I was a
make-a-wish kid I was a make-a-wish kid
and I came on a set of Smallville 16
years ago and she started telling me you
know changed her life and how nice I was
how nice everyone was and it was just an
emotional thing so I posted on an
Instagram it's a wonderful story amidst
all the horror out there but half hope
man I think one other thing that gets
annoying is how many how many people are
get you get these articles every day
right we get these articles like Oh
check this out they said that this is
gonna happen oh look at this
some guys got a cure in Albuquerque oh
and it just goes on and on it's so much
that you're just like and then you do it
too you find some morsel of hope that
hey someone's gonna have a cure and I
think their work and I think they are
getting close and I think we should have
hope and it's good to have hope and you
know it's just important to just love
each other love the [ __ ] out of each
other and you know what I love this guy
Michael Rooker Walking Dead
Henry portrait of a serial killer
guardians of the galaxy 1 & 2 I got to
work with him he's wonderful he's
intense he's hilarious you gotta check
him out let's get inside of Michael
Rooker
it's
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
I think if so then you're married yeah
you've been married for how long
she won't watch this don't marry men
Ryan have you done some research I have
nobody able to guess is it something you
know oh geez you believe in Mary well
you have a grandkid so I'm guessing you
probably you've been married 40 or 38
years what a chump no truths in it
yeah about that 38 years it's about
writing that in an area yeah your wife
probably what's her name she doesn't
like to be talked to talked about a mrs.
Rooker was that safe to say yes right
mrs. Rooker does she
she knows you so well that she probably
just like she doesn't even like does she
call you out on [ __ ] you just seem like
someone that I've known you a while I've
known you well I've seen you you're fun
you're always spontaneous you're always
up to no good but you got a big heart
but I'm just saying someone who's
married to you so much she doesn't did
she didn't call me out I mean uh on what
you know does she ever say what she said
she thinks I'm crazy when I want to
drive all the way across country so I
was getting to pick up a rifle all right
truck to pick up a new new beau is
something you do is this something that
you will go for you'll take a flight
somewhere or dry the hours or take picks
up something you like that's right
well I I worked for a UPS at one point
in time or how long has happened since
before Harry I know you're a good truck
driver
I Drive yeah I'm a good driver I like
driving I I can drive for many hours
what is it about driving that you love
so much
there's gotta be something yeah by
myself that's what it is isn't it yeah
because I noticed like when you when you
go to these cons when you're on set
everybody's like focused on you you know
energy and full of life
yeah but yeah well you got your downtime
you get you down time so driving was a
nice nice break cool just chill out on
your own and I'll stop when you want to
stop you know where do you stop train
stops do you see a Hardee's it's hardly
still exist
dude Hardee's is a big company
I think Carl's jr. though they still
exist dude wouldn't know it did not
I think it did right did it really no I
think they both exist is one thing I
think it's hardest when she crossed the
oh brother chain yeah but what you say
truck stops you stop what do you do at a
truck stop
it's just so you get some water you
stretch your legs yeah yeah yeah then
you stop at your hotel and just choose a
hotel you don't hang out a fancy guy you
stay out like what the nights a lot of
choice another choice there's more
choices than you think
but Quinta welcome it is a fancy place
okay
sounds fancy Holiday Inn Express Holiday
Inn you Best Westerns turn the light on
you know what's that one motel 6 Oh baby
motel 6 turn the light on
ok do you like lettuce save a buck cause
you're a guy who has a lot of money been
working in the industry a long time I
always try to save a buck obviously you
went to Wisconsin he's blue to Wisconsin
has save 10 grain on it on a beautiful
truck which is parked yeah filling up
three driveways outside pretty much it's
a huge truck it is huge it's it's you
know what well I have an Airstream so
I'm gonna tow this Airstream and the
airstream is an old-style Airstream
that's all the silver roundish ones
that's out now all buff down it's
beautiful and it's looking new and it's
very cool and if I'm gonna and if I have
it ever have it towed or if it's ever
towed
you
it's gonna be by me heard of other
people breaking my [ __ ] okay who breaks
your [ __ ] all the Teamsters when they
drive my trailer to and from sets but
that's not your trailer no that's my
trailer they've rented my trailer
oh so they my you to use your air
stretch right and so these Teamsters on
whether it's guardians of the galaxy
citizens I'm not pointing anyone out
several movies and I've been asked I've
had this thing for 28 years they don't
take care of it well they try to take
care of it but sometimes crap falls off
the back of the truck hits the way you
know actually warming people I gotta get
it fixed
almost every movie that I took it on I
had to get it fixed and you make the
studio pay for it well they have well
they paper they don't argue about that
you know okay it's insured and all that
stuff now what's the first thing you do
when you're on set you go who's the head
of Transpo here al come here for a
second scratch my speed is that the new
picture you making the point you go al
this is my Airstream I've had I know
you're gonna say gonna take care of but
in the past this thing's gotten effed up
so I'm asking you to take extra
precaution I do I do it's getting better
and they will and they do you know but
accidents happen so you're expecting
this Airstream to get [ __ ] up usually
when yet but when you tow it fine
[Laughter]
on a very on a in a truck that was way
less truck than I needed to tow it run
and it was not fun so this time when I
bought a truck I bought a truck that's
you know it's an old truck it's enough
truck it's built to tow that and pull
that with no problem there's mrs. Rooker
go with you on any trips to camp you
can't you can't bright times she'll camp
with you no I this this was only for
business right for business but what do
you do oh yeah I never use it for
camping so for camping what you do I
just rent a tent yeah but you're ten you
buy yeah yeah
yeah but I would I would take this now
to the woods park is someplace yeah are
you someone who could like if you're
left in a jungle or left in the woods
for like a week you could get by if I
were left in the woods for a week you
know like these shows they have they
have make it an afraid I'm afraid it's
not my show well what's the other one
survival survival or the Sun doesn't
survive Survivor survivor right because
you can't do that if your shell with the
blonde hair and he's got the knife under
study that's a Beastmaster I don't know
I don't know master that was a good
movie I like the shows you know they're
smart show do you think you could do it
though do you look at them go I could
[ __ ] do that these idiots I could do
that well yeah I played I lived in the
woods all my life practically where'd
you live again not Georgia goddamn oh
yeah so you can't have my life Alabama
the rest was in Chicago you can start a
fire right away I guess I could start a
fire how would you do it if you didn't
have a lighter if you didn't have a
lighter
yeah I you would be prepared okay first
off you would be prepared if you ever
found yourself unprepared then you're in
trouble and you kiss yeah it's still
possible you know it's still possible
with friction and if you have cord take
your shoelaces off you tie the little
thing on the thing with this the stick
and you rub it and you rub it until
friction happens and you we have dries
good stuff you know from bark or
something under it so you're some kind
of underbrush that's dry hopefully it's
not raining big trouble oh yeah yeah and
even with that you can still find stuff
I would love to see a show called
camping with Rooker you just out there
with other idiot celebrities but you
know you know how to survive nothing
could you imagine you're out there with
me trying to show me how to do [ __ ]
Merle Dixon was that was like my home
away from home character role Dixon
could do anything in the woods survive
find food whatever he needed to do
shelter of some kind and that's kind of
basically what I could do
you can do those things I can do now
it's funny you bring up that I was gonna
bring this up but it was all over the
place and I know you but you're glad
it's all about being prepared yeah
anything else you go into the woods
without a pistol yeah you're an idiot a
pistol a rifle pistol whatever you write
a bow something protect yourself well
not necessarily to protect yourself but
to to if you need to hunt or something
like that you can but it's awful also
for oh you know we're not head of the
food chain out there Bo
right you know in case you didn't
realize that yeah yeah we could get
eaten
oh sure easily okay we're gonna attack
by an animal oh yeah I was attacked by a
terrier what's a dog a dog yeah
look at mine it's just I bit my thigh
did you have to take care of the dog I
chased it two blocks while its owner was
chasing me yelling he [ __ ] you good
you're with me I'm bleeding I'm waiting
yeah just the doctor right away you're
like hey I could have something here now
his dog I knew the dog and I knew him
but he calmed me down
well no I calmed myself down because I
got exhausted the dog ran all the way
home I didn't I'm not gonna chase it all
now with you do you feel like walking so
this dog bit you you seem like a guy
that you know you're calm you're cool
you're whatever I would if something
happened I was snap I was still kind of
snapped okay I would still come I'm so
very cool
when the dog bit me he jumped up bit me
right in the groin groin area yeah yeah
dude land it on the ground looked up at
me again I looked down at it
I didn't say anything and it took off
the new it read my mind it new fighter
flight I saw in my eyes and he smelled
my intention was to take it and smash it
upside the building somewhere you know
yeah you know bite me this is about that
but it it ran away and I'm glad I did
cuz it's a cute little dog right right
right I didn't know I really wouldn't
want to hurt that now see what I'm
thinking is when people watching all
these movies and you're biting dogs well
look what I'm thinking is like you have
a you have a temper you're one of those
guys can you really have you can you you
could lose your [ __ ] right but can you
lose your [ __ ] now cuz I know you
meditate you do all this [ __ ] I I can
get upset but you probably have sort of
a controlled upset
can you go data can sometimes I get
upset just for the show
so you're just pretend angry at times so
you're just saying I want people to
think I'm crazy but I'm really in
control of what I'm doing well I don't
think that much about it but I'm very
forgiving person right you know if you
do something to me right and you're
really sorry I won't hurt you with a
bunch of lug I would bite you back you
probably I would have bit the dog back
you would have yeah I wouldn't pick them
up and bit his little nose pick him up
but his face in my face and I go what do
you think about this he would survive
Ryan loves this there was posts
everywhere Twitter Instagram everything
it said Merle the Rosen borough didn't
come back or whatever AMC is cheap
we're great and you love it that was
grueling she were they of course they
were cheap come on give me a break
are you serious nobody got any money
those first three four seasons and you
busted your ass no we killed it dude we
worked our asses off and we made that
series okay but nobody got any money I
mean we got paid really basics basic
salaries but of course you know the show
becomes popular and then now you know
they start paying people after that but
I don't blame them I'd do the same thing
why would I want to pay top dollar on a
show that's not proven and you know and
and if I could get really good actors to
do this for less money go for it after
it becomes it no that's my producer
brain thinking never become a bona fide
hit aren't you thinking you know I
deserve a little more money now yeah of
course you do in the end they do they
get more money now right but you you got
not the beginning ones right not the new
guys Manorama and all those guys get
plenty money right yeah yeah yeah but
you were it they deserve it dude
everybody gets hurt on that show you
know yeah we're running through woods
jumping over logs dodging rattlesnakes I
mean come on you haven't heard
everything what did you feel what was
the worst day where you're like I I hurt
myself here I'd never hurt myself on the
show are you smart enough to go stop man
I'm not doing that [ __ ] oh no I gave a
stock I get the stunt guy I'm always we
didn't really have any stunt guys at
that time we did everything ourselves we
did all the fighting all the rolling
around in the mud and dirt and the blood
and the beer and and everything and we
did it all our so did you get along with
the most I'm walking down honestly the
one guy you like I like to see him I
like to talk to him he's fun or her you
know Nemean Norman got along just fine
and we we like to hanging out and
talking um I you know you're so
beautiful is there so busy you really
don't unless you make a superhuman
effort to hang out right you don't hang
out you go home you go to your hotel in
your sleep you're exhausted
Norman would go home without cleaning up
and taking makeup office so they just
stink you're so tired dude you just you
you quit they wrap you you don't we you
don't want to take the 30 minutes or
whatever it takes to get cleaned up you
just hop on your bike and you go and I
need a shower when you get home did you
notice anybody did that many times they
kind of played the part who just like is
like that kind of actually stinks like
his character would mmm you know I think
we all probably were especially those
hot days in Atlanta right dude it's hot
and it's sweaty there's nothing much you
can do about it well you exhausted you
think you're gonna pass Alec I [ __ ]
I'm tired
no no I've never never I never felt that
on that show at all
I even on the rooftop when it was
wonderful to know when a hand
handcuffed other people are getting weak
and passing out I was just sittin loose
passing out a couple couple you're on
the show anymore cut a couple of the
actors um guys girls both yeah passing
out like get a hot water getting you
know if you got a paramedic here getting
weak yeah
almost passing and you were like holy
[ __ ] people are passing out yeah dude I
I kept drinking I I kept hydrating but
that doesn't help sometimes
what water for example I just did a
movie in Fiji Fantasy Island I heard
about that
it's a bloom yeah you know house yep
yeah is it good
it's guy just saw it as good okay like
it okay and my first two three days on
that show were the hardest most
dangerous working days I had ever ever
done on any show ever
wait am I saw that I was with just
watching re watching sea of love with
your machine with Pacino where you're
fighting and that scene is the most
intense scene that goes on harder than
that
Oh harder than that I had never felt as
though I think I'm gonna pass out and
that happened on Fantasy Island my first
two days I'm fighting this guy that's
like seven foot tall
quite 280 pounds and we're rolling
around in the dirt and the gravel and
the top of a mountain there's no air
conditioning there's and I was it and I
don't like to eat and snack like a lot
of other actors we need that don't you
that's my mistake I do you do need it
because I was I was depleting all of my
electrolytes I was sweating I I was
drinking plenty of water but the doctor
when he got there was saying look what's
going on is that you've depleted your
electrolytes now you're drinking a lot
of water you've been drinking a lot of
water but all you're doing is are you
are basically exhausting your hydrated
you're hydrating yourself but you are
diluting the electrolytes that you still
have so what I needed to do even more
than drink water was to have some sort
of a drink with electrolytes and that's
basically what happened that helped yeah
yeah he gave me a couple he gave me some
powdered electrolytes I took two of
those guys half a bottle each and and
within 20 minutes I felt well you
worried though like oh my god am I
getting old is something happening to me
am I gonna well I was like honestly in
between takes I would just drop to the
ground I was on the ground people had
umbrellas over me I mean it happened
quickly it happened yeah yeah it was
like there was no stopping we were
working all day long in this heat and
you know I don't need exhaustion heat
struck once where and it was an his in
Wisconsin actually I had when you were I
had heat stroke once oh not this on this
show but I knew it was coming because I
had had it before and I knew wow if if
we keep going like this that something's
gonna happen what happens when you get
heatstroke oh I was standing next to my
motorcycle
and the next moment I'm watching my feet
being drugged into the shade passed out
I totally passed up yeah totally passed
I was going to hospital out like a light
next thing I knew I felt this weight on
my chest and somebody had dumped the
cooler on my chest to cool my body down
and I felt fine after about an hour or
so but but after that it took me about a
year and a half or so to get unscented
for my body to recoup and get and feel
okay in the Sun it's tough it's a really
bad cetera so that I felt in doing the
Fiji show that was really hard now I'm
gonna see it just to see how what you
were doing what if they cut it did they
cut it all it's just like one thing
wrong like that's it it was nuts so
after that though I learn learn my
lesson snack a little bit snack what
kind of snacks you know it can be nuts
cheese something snacking some nuts
fruit you know yeah yeah something like
carry yourself Wilson just anything that
has some sugar some you know
electrolytes and drink of course hydrate
right but don't over hydrate your
educating people oh dude hey serious I'm
telling you I've done so many movies and
I never get hurt and and and I just keep
going and going and going there's no I'm
like the the Machine yeah and they don't
get anxiety I don't get anxiety I don't
get tired I guess it never I one of the
few actors that have come on here and
said yeah just don't get anxiety you you
really have never been [ __ ] I'm anxious
and nervous about something I can't
[ __ ] get it I don't know you get that
I don't get that you don't get you don't
give a [ __ ] no I don't I don't you
really don't ever care no this is true
no matter what you never get embarrassed
other people on the set and they're like
no Roku doesn't know his lines no I
don't [ __ ] oh my lines no I don't
about knowing my lens I mean absolutely
no moves really you know your lines you
know your stuff so if you go up or down
or inside out in between lines you're
changing them you're fixing them usually
yeah but sometimes like when you work a
gun you don't need to fix anything it's
just the script says is it's great stuff
so you learn it way ahead of time right
what yeah you want to say you want to do
it because it's so well bloody written
you want to do it the way it's written
do you yeah script and you're you can
tell me if I'm over exaggerating but 90%
of all scripts you want to change it
it's gas because it sucks and by the way
that's the hardest to memorize lines
when they're and I was it's you you told
me something once where it's like then
they have vignettes or like the RET regi
lines or have this because it was they
gave you a monologue or some [ __ ] like
oh no I just I did this year this past
year a TV show with Moe Herschel Ali oh
you do don't say detective Trudy to
Detective yeah yeah awesome I had two
days to learn a nine-page walk and talk
obviously that ain't happening and even
for the best of us that ain't happening
I probably turn that down
I guess [ __ ] out of me no you know I
don't know why are you doing that I know
I should have turned it down but my
friend Sackheim was directing it and he
said come and do it and I said okay and
I said okay I do a lot of things for
friends that sometimes I shouldn't but I
should have said dude like a Spock
not enough time well exactly this part
yeah exactly you know you're not having
fun so yeah I get there and it's it's
it's ridiculous and we talk and I say
this ain't happening come on how's that
how's this possible what'd he say to you
if there's gonna take this this look we
got to do this in one day give me a
break
nine pages nine pages and one day walk
and talk a lot of it most of it any
said well we have this actor that does a
lot of the voice-over stuff for us and
he uses an ear and that's what I want to
do he uses an inner ear in 87 would you
like to try that I'd say I've never done
and I've heard about it of course and he
said would you like to try it I said
there's no other choice dude let's just
do it
I mean there's no way I got with the
other script lady and you weren't
nervous at all
no I wasn't nervous it was a challenge
so I don't get it was a great gesture
let's see how this led run yeah let's
see how it works so I got with them the
lady in she has an accent
so I'm like oh great so she's gonna be
the reader and she's gonna let me set it
up okay so an earwig is pretty much he
has a piece in his ear if you don't know
if you're an actor you probably know it
but you have an ear what Brando used one
I think Robert Downey jr. might use it
every once in a while I want to use it
and rooker used one so they put in your
ear and then someone reads usually
you've rehearsed it in the sense that
they know your cadence the reach of the
lines how you want to deliver them so he
was sort of on the fly and now she's
delivering them off camera on a little
microphone that's transferring the
information and hearing her voice so you
there are no wires right no wires right
especially if you have long hair you
don't you don't ever see it and so I
said yeah let's do it
so that's the that's the setup so we got
there we rehearsed about an hour and a
half and then we started shooting hour
and a half of you with the earwig yeah
me and her on our own you just feel like
I was getting there well you know what
it worked great I realized as soon as we
started doing it that I had been doing
this all my life I don't I don't have
the luxury of having a person with me
all the time working and running lines
so I use a tape recorder to get the
basics of my lines right all right and
it's it's just it's repetition over and
over and over and over driving across
country to your set by the time you get
to the set you know you're lying
listening to them so what you do is you
put it so it's a like rookery you might
go I don't give a [ __ ] what you tell me
I'm doing this and then there's a little
blank area the other guy's line and then
your next line or whatever else you want
to do it right do it too different I do
it two or three different ways I do the
entire script both sides those lines
yeah your line they're long and I do and
then I do a version that has that
person's lines and now that my lines so
you just hear them go I don't care about
that and then so you could say go so I
self so I say my lines to myself so I
get the right timing for the for the the
break for the quiet break right and and
then and then I that's how I do it
that's how I I start out with both lines
if it depends on how long I've been with
the script sometimes it's like two days
you get the script you got to be unset
in four days
right and stuff like that so that's what
I had been doing all my life so when I
got with the script girl for true
detective it was like I'd been doing it
forever well not only that [ __ ] but
this is where because you don't really
imagine going on set going I know what's
happening I just need somebody to say
the lines to me and then I say them so
for instance let me be the girl with an
accent I'll do it let's do it okay go
ahead say whatever you want say Irish
for instance of France is what I don't
care what you do I don't care what you
give this is the reality this is a
reality I don't give a f--- at all I've
said this I said there's a one more time
one more time that's really [ __ ] I
don't give two [ __ ] you seen this movie
my dick you loose your [ __ ] ass a DI
ck but see that's how that's how do do
do me do me see if I can do it what do
you want me to do what you want me to do
you're late you're late you're late
you're late it's too late it's too late
it's got to be almost on Thomas right on
top of how you're getting now you get
that's how you do it man that's it
that's it and then you add your own
little things in there they do the
reading you do the acting don't now what
are you doing yeah if there's other
actors around it doesn't matter so every
better on cue as long as they know their
lines but so your person's got to be
listening for their lines to be on cue
to give you the line well of course yeah
that's how it's done
and what do you do though you go so
let's say [ __ ] Ryan says the line
then I say a line there's nothing from
you and you're like hey it's not my
fault the person saying my lines they
didn't know I don't do that but when I
when I was there that's I had no other
choice and so we ended up dude we ended
up but you've seen the scene yeah it's a
killer singular scene there was I never
would've thought hell you could tell and
it was and it was it as an actor
gave me more freedom to respond in a
more in an even more spontaneous so why
don't you do that so I don't you do to
get forever I would do it again it and
many many we'll do it again any time you
just say every move you gave lookit I
love doing this so just have some of the
Karimi the lines
yeah well that's great I would do that
you want to hire me I mean their movie
let's do a movie yeah okay I'll do the
whole move higher how confusing that
would be that would be so crazy
be so crazy you know what's funny is you
know if there's no I would do that again
I would do it again especially if it's a
nine-page there were a tubular save my
ass
save the production's ass saved time we
got through the entire nine pages
without one flub or you look amazed by
it
I look at zip free god what does it get
was you know what it ends up being
honest honest to god it it is one of the
most wonderful tools in your tool chest
that you could ever have and sometimes
you have to draw upon and sometimes you
don't depends on how much time these
producers and Studios give you as an
actor so now when someone says hey can
you do this and you're thinking oh my
god no let me that there's too much
material not enough time what am i no
I'm not that stupid and you can just say
yeah no problem
you lose yes now you've got the way you
wake up there's no stress what's that I
have to [ __ ] memorize my lines all
night there's no spell and you're
spontaneous and if you're given these
lines it's real and you're even more
spontaneous than trying to memorize your
head cuz you're thinking it's what
contrived so what if for instance I'm
gonna do it one more time what if you're
a little angry it's emotional you have
to really listen to it so it's like I
don't give a [ __ ] you're talking to me
about I don't I don't want the person to
do it that way you don't know I want the
person to read I don't give a [ __ ] what
you say not even not even
that I don't give a [ __ ] what you say
yeah and then you say emotion yeah if
you just do it no I'm over just normal
all right
okay ready I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
would you say you're a piece of money
that's [ __ ] prick
so there you go what if you have your
heart of hearing then you I would adjust
the sound in turn but it but if it's too
loud then you get feedback from the
other mic that are Kosovo or a coast the
other actor you're gonna get you're
gonna get a technical feat and there's
some sort of feedback and it's not good
and the director loved what you did
everybody loved what I did so they're
like and everybody knew he's getting
where you're with nobody knew what do
you know on the other set yeah no people
catch it but people who saw it had no
not even an inkling
isn't that the can they loved isn't that
got so many crew your texts your honor
kudos from that scene from that show and
I'm telling you and I you know I don't
see it as a crutch as a crutch
whatsoever I see it as a an amazing tool
that I got to experience and it worked I
think I would do what do you like to try
it once I did try it yeah I want to live
it honestly they hey you shooting a
movie next week we wanted to come and do
this scene it's true
Greg I could do the whole movie you give
me I don't even know there's there's
young to prepare yeah of course you
gotta know what happens well you're
gonna know everything that you already
do in your preparation as an actor yeah
you still must yeah absolutely yeah it
albeit when you only have two days
there's not much good to you know you
just have to be your instincts have to
sort of take over and and that's you
know as an actor as a human being who
knows how to read and comprehend and
understand what's written you're gonna
get the idea absol okay
should unless it's in other really
seriously a multi-layered dimensional
script that yeah why would they watch
you why were they put you in a two day
situation like that right so it was a
two day situation they by the way look
at Michael Rooker and think he galore
nine pages in two days not know I'm not
looking at you saying you couldn't do it
I know or any actor I not just Rooker
anybody I say yeah I could deliver nine
pages to you yes those people are
probably the people that can do that
that's one of those rarities that you
just go wow you're [ __ ] I don't know
I died yeah you know what but then that
that calls into question their their
internal preparation they're just
they're just repeating they're just like
they just have to memorize along just
memorizing in store and spitting them
out this is better than that
you're not memorizing lines and spitting
them out on set you know you are taking
the line into your brain and your brain
is Germany in an interpretation
instantaneous and you were that's why I
said to the reader said look you read I
act that's all we have to do and we'll
get through this and she tried it first
like don't do this look it's really hard
for the readers I think because they
tend to want to help so much that they
try to help you don't want them to help
the only help that they need to do is
just to read it and read it in a natural
cadence and normal that would act for
good as me taking a long beat what if
you're like this she says they they have
to know what you're doing they have to
be in visual contact it's really nice
when they're in visual contact but when
they're not they have to you will have
to had rehearsed enough for them to know
when you can slow down right all right
and because they can you know so Sally
it's like this Sally so after he says I
am gonna I'm gonna hate I generally tell
them wait 10 seconds gonna this is
this has to have its own mama
okay and you'll understand when I begin
again so she's like she takes a moment
then she forgets cuz her phone she's
like and I'm sitting there waiting there
for two minutes he's like oh [ __ ] no
[ __ ] there are people I was in the line
there are people who do this
professionally and they they know it's a
it's a very concentrated energy and
effort especially if this there's long
monologues involved if there are scenes
like I had like bloody nine page walk
and talk ended up being more like a four
or five page right maybe a four page
walking talk and then the rest was on
that ledge it was a great scene alone
and it came out really good it was great
I was actually very proud of my season 3
made entry you know Sean Gunn a good
friend of both of ours he was on the
podcast yeah yeah and he you know he got
yes work together Guardians I think
Suicide Squad whatever he says I loved
your interview with Rooker the first
time cuz he got real he got a little you
know not emotional but like and I was
like really I said huh he he went on
about it he doesn't know what he's
talking about doesn't know he's talking
no I know you had a grandkid something
kids yeah I got two girls did did you
cry when they were born know that a
happiness no like it's a question ever
why would I cry yeah crying give me a
break yeah geez
I mean your wife mrs. Walker's seen you
mr. Rooker emotional have you ever been
emotional you're hiding are you a cry
don't cry don't cry why hey babe why
should I cry no you were a tough kid
growing up you had a lot of [ __ ] crying
here there's no crime yeah you know we
don't do no crying yeah it's matter with
you you say that's your grandkids we
don't know hey stop the crying I bet
you're a lovable little nah come on hey
no crying what what makes Rooker's heart
just okay what makes his heart just he
just completely melts what have none I
don't have a hot [ __ ] my heart there's
some and there is no there's something
inside you that when something happens
some you you melt
it's one thing to see well there's
certain things when I you know when I I
don't know sometimes if I do charity
work or if I have a connection or
someone I could cry I could open up a
little bit yeah not not easily it's it's
it's come out more you know you do
everything its life so it happens it
doesn't matter what happens whenever it
happened what's the last time it
happened you're driving from Wisconsin
in your new truck I cried during love
scenes you know what scenes whatever
scenes when I'm watching a movie and
there's something's emotional like why I
I am clear-eyed blend in with the actors
and I'm there and I see it and and it's
emotional and especially especially if
if it you know if they're doing a good
job the actors I saw you in the premium
engines the galaxy to when the on dude
eyes yeah and I looked over you were
like in the room in front of me cuz you
were one of the stars and I had a small
role but I looked over and you were just
yet tears in your eyes I did you did I
remembered you remember obviously you
know I was like oh because I thought it
was a great moment I look at you to see
how you were responding to your
informants of yahoodi' and I could see
you were emotional yeah there are no
tears though I didn't see tears I was a
little far there were no tears yeah I I
had just had some onions you know what
was going through your mind when that
happened like this is such a sick booby
snack of onions you know I wasn't really
thinking too much about that when yondu
dies I wasn't thinking about when yondu
dies I'm I'm yondu in the scene so I
don't I'm not thinking about I'm dying
what I was thinking of what you're
thinking hey this is really the end of
guardians for me no I wasn't thinking
that at all what do you think just watch
I wasn't thinking anything you just say
this actor is great I just doing the
scene that was it yeah no I meant when
you're watching yondu yeah yes we talked
about yeah yeah
you're watching the scene you're
watching yondu so you're just watching
the movie yeah you weren't able to step
outside and just watch yourself as an
actor play this blue character yeah
although I'm a little bit when I watch
scenes and things that I'm doing I'm
always wondering I don't know if I could
do that better
that was that was as great as I could
possibly be great at you know that's a
great feeling you know sometimes I have
encountered times when I go that that
needed to have this you didn't get it I
didn't quite get it no I never do
anything ever ever ever that I don't get
right I gotta get it or who I do it okay
I don't I I can't do that if I gotta
believe it or I don't want to do it so I
gotta take the moment take the time take
whatever I need to take well to
understand why I'm saying what I'm
saying for example you have a glass of
water yeah you know and you're putting a
drop in that glass of water and it's
filling up filling up to the brim
I don't say anything I don't want to say
anything until that water is spilling
over them that's your line that's your
voice as the water spills over that's
when you speak you don't speak before
you don't that's why I don't like to
rehearse either man I don't want I don't
want to do that you want to feel phony
until it loses its luster ready to go
you hate it you hate rehearsing I
rehearse at a certain level and that's
it hey this is where I'm going this is
what I'm gonna be doing I'm gonna saying
this and now that's it let's move on
yeah otherwise it's gonna make you kind
of talk about talk it out and I don't
want to talk stuff out that much he's
drunk
I'll talk with him but I don't want talk
with the other actors and like I'd
rather you guide me while we're doing it
then to just get it all out now and then
you're like oh this is what he's gonna
do or this is what I'm gonna do it'd be
nice to not know what I'm gonna do right
I don't want to know what I'm gonna do I
don't want to know what you're gonna do
I try my best to not know your lines
I don't even want to know my lines I
honestly I want my lines to be as fresh
to me as they are to you when you hear
them so if I could if if I can do that
that satisfies me you know you know as
an actor as an artist I want it to be as
spontaneous and fresh as possible and
sometimes it's really hard to do that
it's really hard to get that that that
that approach is I don't know if I don't
know what your is that you kind of do
the same thing or I don't like to
rehearse
especially comedy I don't like to
rehearse comedy yeah I just feel like
you're gonna lose it you're gonna lose
it cut it be spontaneous I don't like it
not much different than you know pretty
straight from and it's hard when P other
actors wanna rehearse I need to rehearse
this is how I want to do it and then you
have to sort of go okay [ __ ] I don't to
be a dick but like okay I'm gonna give
it to you but I'm not gonna give it to
you mind rehearsing in the early stages
of just read just just learning lines
right that's what I've been that's what
you do is fine but that's what you do
anyway but I'd rather not know how you
gonna do it yeah it sort of defeats that
whole purpose of being fresh with me
yeah I'm you what you're gonna say I
don't know what you're gonna say I don't
want to know what you're gonna say I
don't want to hide a lot I don't want to
know how are you gonna say what if I
have a line and you cut me off because
you don't know what I'm gonna say I
don't know I have a [ __ ] other line
dude it happens so what are you doing go
with it stop being such a whiny whip so
for instance let's say a friend if I go
go and then at the end of the take you
can go back over and you go oh I missed
that line but don't stop the take while
it's going so you're very sick mistakes
can be a lot of fun but if you ever say
that oh I've had actors stop I've had
I've seen actors stop is about you not
being in the scene but I've seen actors
stop because if somebody messes up but
those mess ups
can be completely golden they can yield
such precious jewels that you would not
even can't even imagine coming out of
your mouths out of the act other actors
mouths and your mouth as well it can
change the whole scene but so what they
can either keep it or throw it out go
back and you can do the lines you can do
it the way it's written if you want you
know of course you can this was just a
little flub mistake but I don't like
stopping unless unless you're just
[ __ ] it up yeah mmm mauling yeah
completely off base yeah hey you uh
you're in Suicide Squad Yeah right yeah
are you done filming I'm done filming
was it enjoyable it was great I've never
seen James so laid-back when he came for
Christmas and I saw him when I came back
there just seems like he there's a
calmness about think is it just like
he's not bound up he does day and night
day and night I never ever want to be a
director that's just the hardest job
ever cuz you're gonna worry about
everything it's 24/7 dude even if you
sleep it's a miracle because you're
constantly thinking about the other
actors their scenes the relationships
the the the sets that lenses and all
kinds of crap I just offered to direct a
movie now I don't think I want to after
it is hard
give 24/7 all all in if you are okay
with that
I do it through the feature and I was
the lead in it was the biggest mistake
of my life because it was just too hard
no buts directing it alone is enough
yeah everybody's telling me gum was like
that what are you doing don't be the
leader I guess I almost died at the end
of these [ __ ] things no it's tough
it's really really it's unbelievably
brutal on your psyche and now like you
have to deal with everybody else's
problems so you don't wanna do with that
you know no I don't want to deal with
your problems no I don't even want to
know your product you want to do your
own problem I don't want to do
from true right what was your problems
in your problems you do got a seat
together do your stupid scene man I'm
not gonna direct you I'm gonna sit back
and watch your scene if I believe your
scene then we'll move on if I don't
believe your scene if you're giving me
[ __ ] then I'm gonna smack you upside
the head
there you go yeah that's how you write
that am i right you think's huh
that's my directing the audience threes
gonna happen do you think you're gonna
be in it and for any reason know why I'm
dead I'm dead
well they bring you back as a different
character my character is dead could you
play something else I would play
something else I wouldn't really like
something else I would play something
else but I wouldn't wait why would I
want to play yandi I do had a wonderful
most amazing send-off that you would
ever want in in cinematic Marvel history
history my god dude
why do you want to spoil that by
bringing the character back now yeah
alright with a gun there's there's
consequences when you die you're
supposed to stay dead there's no
consequences when you die you're dead
give me a break yeah I don't like that a
lot of movies it's like you know
everybody's older everybody dies deals
like it come on who's dead Hey look I
don't mind if everybody dies as long as
I'm doing the killing that's right true
by the way and see love and we talked
about in the beginning that scene you
have to see see develop but there's this
scene that's great where I couldn't
believe I didn't I watched it but you
with Pacino you're beating the [ __ ] out
of each other
yeah and you get on him yeah from behind
yeah yeah I know that you came up with
this cuz it wasn't written oh I'm gonna
rape him like he I'm gonna you think
that he take his clothes off you think
he reigns Oh raping and kill him because
you think someone he raped someone you
loved yeah and you are now on top of him
when I see this you're not obviously
your club but you're beating the [ __ ]
and he's got him he's beating the [ __ ]
him and then he acts just like he's
grinding him at the end I was like [ __ ]
that was your choice wasn't it director
didn't say Rucker can you act like
you're [ __ ] out yo though well the
lines give you your hints your lies the
line do you remember the line the line
was what did you do
[ __ ] me what you did do is show me how
you did it you know
and as I'm ripping his clothes off and
I'm about to I'm about to rape this guy
and then kill him boys brains out right
and so in the meantime he grabs the the
little rope locks you in the head Rodya
clocks me in the head and then the
fights on right a dumbbell or some yeah
it was a trophy it was a shooting
atrophic and he hits me in the head and
I go back and then we worked out with
the stunt guys and with him we we both
did a lot of our own style on that take
the choreograph that see him and how
long did it take to shoot it took about
a day a full day that was out great to
work with yeah I thought he was great to
work it well he we understood each other
really crystal clear after the first
take how so well first take he tried
choking me up what's really like really
hurt like really and then what'd you do
oh I did what I was supposed to do in
the scene which was spin around and to
launch my 210 pound frame with him on my
back into the wall and you did it of
course a little harder a little extra
huh I did it his way you supposed to do
it did you hurt him I think we were both
hurting at that point and did he say hey
sorry about that no he looked up to me
after he after he fell from my back and
his arms left my neck he looked up at me
he said am i [ __ ] you know you don't see
the choking too hard am i he said it
he's a - huh am I too hard and I go did
I too hard and he goes that was it that
was it
we understood each other crystal but you
weren't gonna stop that scene you're
like Al Pacino's choked I mean I'm not
gonna stop no no no if I stopped I would
have been I would have been taken out he
would have put me to sleep
it's the most intense scene it sounds
like a light-hearted romp oh my god I
totally would have been put to sleep I
was going out I was seeing nothing but
black black black black black
was there any kind of conversation where
you guys talk did you talk a lot did you
or did you just do your work the only
thing we talked a little bit but we were
both into the scene and when I was on
him on top of him and we were in between
takes I remember him saying Rooker could
you like lighten up a little bit
oh yeah yeah yeah oh yeah cuz I was just
resting I was just like waiting for the
seem to be oh oh wait it ready for it's
a cut again I'm just hanging out could
you like let up a little bit it was like
I was 210 pounds at that time almost all
muscle and and I was like oh my god yes
of course did you go to the premiere and
I realized the jitters premiere for it
yeah did he come up to you oh he's great
job in that question oh dude we both did
a great job it was a wonderful sequence
and and um it was but he's pleasant to
work with he knew his lines was equally
when you were working with him because
he's known as one of the best actors in
the history of yeah he's great did you
always know his [ __ ] inside out and he
was just like what his work ethic how
what did you notice about that work
ethic with Al Pacino it was no different
than the the energy he puts into his
work is was no different than the energy
I put into my work or the energy that
any actor would put into their work to
make sure that they do it almost I don't
know if this is true but my goal is to
do the scene once and then move on I
wish that was the case you can't be the
case all you got to do is
have three or four cameras that's what
we did on the rooftop scene in the
walking dead when I'm chained to the
rooftop they had five cameras going all
at the same time we did that we did it
two takes and that was it we moved on
yeah most the time no matter how good
you are there's another and another and
a tighter and a tighter and I'm it on
you all got it in one right right
you got the camera that's doing the
tight you got the camera that's doing
the wide you got the camera that's up
top you got the camera you got the point
of view you got the wide angle you got
all these cameras going at the same time
right now as the actor if you can do the
scene like that scene on the rooftop and
do it the way it's supposed to be done
and yet in the know exactly where your
cameras are then you're golden and
that's that's what I did mrs. Walker
that doesn't missus what you are good at
it by though you're great at it I don't
like to say that I'm a technical actor
but that I am but I'm very technically
technical at the same time completely
opposite you know wrong y'all raw and in
the scene yeah and yet still no where
you need to be and when and where that
close-up camera is right you know where
I need to turn and all that this missus
Rooker ever look at you and say she sees
a movie and she goes I thought you were
really wonderful in that did she tell
you those things yeah yeah a lot of
people did well your wife the [ __ ] that
she does she watch the things you do now
of course she does yeah does she ever
tell you anything about it does she does
that mean something to you when you hear
her say she goes yeah you're good they
feel like they always say hey yeah you
know they respect my work they know that
I'm an artist before I'm an actor before
I'm an are any any other art form any
other medium I'm an artist no matter
what what would you do if you didn't act
I'd have a different medium I'm an
artist all right this is [ __ ] talk in
questions from my patrons it's on page
patrons yeah these are these are [ __ ]
coughing questions [ __ ] talking with
Rosenbaum users quit you could answer
them quickly Robert B so my answers are
quick Robert except for all the [ __ ]
that I just said Robert B says do you
have any favorite whiskey drink yet what
he didn't ask that what is it if I asked
Oh what is it I'm I like Jack and Coke I
do too that's it that's a southern with
names I like it a little Jack and Diet
little Jack okay I mean just a taste I
think I Jack Jack oh you know coke two
limes and yeah Nicko P have you always
been so energetic I don't see myself as
energetic but I've always been like this
by the way nobody could sleep like you
nobody could sleep like you you will
sleep on a stet during a scene you will
fall asleep anywhere is that true I can
sleep anywhere anytime listen I can
sleep right now that I are still if I
close my eyes I can go to sleep within a
minute of your sleep right now I could
Jill II what was it like working on
Mallrats it was fun okay thank you Lisa
just wondering if he can ever look at a
chocolate-covered pretzel the same way
if he and if he still eats them I do I
love them what's that from Jerry W I'm
curious what's expected of professional
actors when it comes to memorizing we
already talked about measuring lines how
many pages per day you expected to
commit to memorizing for filming we've
already talked about that Jerry W yeah
yeah that's a that's a stupid question
it's a great question though you got
Rooker to say that there you know like
Ryan H how did you prepare for his role
as Henry Porsche person we talked about
this in the last podcast and I said my
answer was I did there was no
preparation at all needed and did the
role affect you in any way it started
your career sitting here next to me and
when I say there's no preparation have
you seen the movie and the lieutenant oh
my god it's great started his career I
was his breaking he was it was so scary
I love saying that people because then
they just stop no I'm sorry I should
know about oh wait a minute and then I
did I asked you need a ride home yeah I
loved you in slither gun gun directed it
what is your favorite or most memorable
role to date and why your most memorable
role you love jinsol but what's your
most memorable role to date that you
just loved it you're like that's the one
I'll go down for that's the one I love
you know I I have to say that the
rooftop scene in
was well he's dead I can't say what one
it's really tough that's the first one
that came on the one that came to mind
was that one but also the second one is
the moment the moment when I take Chris
Pratt's head in his face in my hands
you know yeah during guardians of galaxy
- yeah that was a beautiful beautiful
beautiful moment and get emotional for
real oh well you how do you know how can
you not yeah we you don't plan on stuff
like that I I don't plan on stuff like
that if it happens it happens
that you do when he takes where you
actually cry we're gonna wanted you to
cry but then then use it I don't ever do
that if some director says that to me I
tell them go [ __ ] off
don't say cry you know don't say
anything I don't know what's gonna
happen in the scene hmm give me a break
how do I know what's gonna happen in the
scene it's just cried on the scene I
don't care what the script says it's
stupid can they do that
that's staging erection reality is this
I will say this Rooker people always try
not to cry in real life yeah yes that's
that's what reality is people try not to
cry is not the goal should never be the
goal as an actor if you you are more apt
to shed a tear if you try not to Tom who
woke you up after the filming was here
that's all you could look at topsis
through woke you up after filming
yondu's funeral scene who woke you up
which time I went to sleep about five or
six I got on the microwave you know well
five or six takes on Michael Michael no
I was I can sleep
know what's going on crazy
you can sleep and still know what's
going on that's unconsciously or
consciously as soon as as soon as the
cut was cut there I wake up as soon as I
thought he's a [ __ ] machine so does
he said action within I don't know 10
seconds or so I was sleeping Joshua H
what actress or actor you didn't know
before filming guardians and pressured
the most after working with them
somebody came to mind
Chris Pratt you didn't really know him I
didn't know him and then he blew you
away yeah yeah I loved him I loved him
he was great a really hard worker and
and now he did a awesome job man he's a
star Jenelle asks what are your best and
worst memories about filming The Walking
Dead well we talked a lot about that
yeah best and worst memories best
memories are you know the camaraderie
lunch
yeah the lunch now lunches were great
the food was good food was the bad thing
knows they were cheaper than pays [ __ ]
the bad thing was that you were dealing
with the environment it is so hot it is
so miserable in the summer time running
around dirty and filthy you know trying
to do uh-uh-uh-uh-uh a scene and they
weren't they weren't that cheap they
paid what they could afford at that time
you know ROG last question have you ever
had any funny crazy interactions was
Stallone between your time on
cliffhanger and guardians well I
remember him guarding yes he the one
who's like couldnt get delighted I know
that wasn't even the best time for me
and him it was me and him I'm a post-it
there's me and him taking selfies of
each other that's standing together like
this we were standing at her like this
and we're taking selfies of each other
yet it looked like we're taking selfies
of ourselves it's like our egos were so
right out there you know it looked as
the way the the angle was it looked as
if I'm taking a picture of myself and
he's taken
picture of itself but we're actually
taking two selfies at the same time you
want to do you think you act for the
rest of your life - is that what you
want - do you think you'll act till you
die look when you're 80 90 or still do
you ever quit did you put a number on it
well you're ever gonna take the
Airstream and go do your thing and say
forget about me I'm done I've done
everything I'm done no I haven't done
everything I have hardly even scratch
the surface one day there will be
someone who will hire me in a role that
we not only scratch the surface but we
[ __ ] blow it up so you still haven't
played that role no I haven't in your
head that is so beyond like like you're
gonna have to dig deep you're gonna have
to have them play the role really Henry
yondu now all these other [ __ ] crazy
roles
no not even scratch the surface I don't
think so
do you think it's gonna be a bad guy a
bad character autumn it's gonna be an
emotional is that what you're talking
about - you feel like be a little ball
that you want to do comedy I'm not a
very funny guy I think you are though
you'd have to pay me a lot of money to
be funny you're funny right now see if
you just kept this face with me right
now
see we could do mutton Jeff you can be
funny if you want but I'm not gonna be
funny but that's what's funny that's
what's funny so you're all full up do a
little stand-up if you want would you
ever go stand-up one thing that scares
you yeah nothing you wouldn't stand up
comedy do it you do stand-up arse you oh
yeah yeah sure swimmer sharks now I
don't swim me sharps would you I don't
swim anywhere where I'm not head of the
food chain
oh do you I did swim ashore no I didn't
I saw I was in the cage
you know swims with sharks idiots you
pretty much shark bait how far do you
live from me
cuz you're gonna go back in your new
truck I was about 40 minutes away and
what do you listen to when you're you
know I just I just put the radio I just
signed up for that radio sirius Sirius
radio yet the truck had it still had
about three months uh of a trial right
and you like to end but I hadn't I
didn't have it on the whole way across
the country you know cuz I didn't want
to stop driving to pull over and take
the time you know I was just driving and
having fun driving listen to country
music I listen to a lot of stuff I
listen the country I like blues I like
jazz like cause I like gospel yeah I
like bluegrass
that's all Alabama [ __ ] now there's no
that's all the Alabama stuff yeah I love
all that stuff this has been great Jeff
fun way to talk about really anything
that we did the first time it's just fun
it's just two guys talking yeah yeah is
that is that the the theme of your show
here no two guys two guys talking about
nothing two guys talking about no it was
you know I like this because you're I
think that should be your theme from now
on because when you start and try to
talk about something it sounds stupid
like what I mean when your other shows
the ones without me all the other side I
know as you can see around here I get
autographs from some posters and [ __ ] no
I like you know some people get me them
sometimes I have a guest no I have a
Karate Kid right do you think it's a do
you think it's weird and be what you
already get you what that's one would
you want of my probably Henry portrait I
mean that's where else
Henry I got you have every poster of a
Henry poster for your ass really hat
will blow you away it is so amazing and
the designer of this poster he only did
like 40 of them really yeah
you'll give me one and sign it yeah I'll
put it up in here I'll give you one I'll
give you one inside it for you [ __ ] yeah
you hear that Ryan do you think it's
weird for actors to get autographs from
other actors no I do sometimes who do
you do but do you get whoever I have
time for so hey if there's a moment in
the in the shoot that I that I have time
Jeana when you're on his back grinding
them did you say hey could I get you
know hey I'll give you out after the
scene Wow what'd you do did you get the
site did you say he didn't sign anything
for you don't be sick who did scene that
was a great scene that was a scary scene
it wasn't scary in beyond intense it was
so intense that I was well I have
forgotten about it
that I was listening it and Jess was on
the other side on our computer going I
didn't need to even see that [ __ ]
scene that's how intense it was that was
that's what she said
very very incredibly real for many very
intense scene yeah so whose autograph
have you gotten I don't even do a real
anymore
I know aa B you don't need want to do
over you I don't have a really more I
have a real friend years ago but what am
i doing real I like doing my Riyas you
have a lot of great stuff I enjoyed
editing my reels you edited your reels
yeah I did all my this is when I was
great I want to do this this is I did
this by the way I couldn't hurt if
somebody's like Michael Rooker oh yeah
I've seen the guy but when you put true
detective a moment you put yondu and you
put [ __ ] you know not maybe I don't
know about fantasy on because I haven't
seen it but you know maybe maybe the
outtakes was dying of heat exhaustion
the Furious 9 I'm in the Suicide Squad
Suicide Squad got all these things in
Henry it's like god this guy give you
everything I'm hiring this guy yeah you
would hope well that's what's happened
well so what autographs yeah no I've
worked a lot I've been very very happy
and very pleased you're grateful with
what's what's been I've been blessed at
getting a chance to do yeah so I won in
one day maybe what autograph do you have
at home that you asked another actor for
an autograph
named it a couple or any-any Oh
I got an autograph from Studs Terkel
suds Studs Terkel
you know Studs Terkel he's a writer
Chicago writer no yeah I should know the
number of the movie 8 min out yeah I
love that yeah he played one of the
reporters and you got an autograph done
with John Sayles
yeah it's great writer look at it well I
should know that I'm pretty ignorant
with a lot of things yeah but see you
yeah you would get my gun he's not an
actor do you wish you would have his
Nonna's autograph or no you know what I
I don't I actually honestly don't think
a lot about it and then once the movies
over and what I do then I I said oh man
I you know I should have had the whole
cast signed a Guardians poster yeah they
do that you know you can hear that you
know we do that yeah but why don't you
get one you know it's funny so please
promise if they're gonna get you one and
they never do by the way let me tell you
something you can get yourself in
autograph guardians poster you can yeah
how did you want me to just get you one
what are you gonna get I'm gonna call
the director of the movie have some
story I'm sure someone's gonna have a
poster they'll give it to you that's
signed by everybody and you put it in
your I don't have one all right oh you
doing a Henry I'll get you a Henry you
get me a Guardian about meeting with the
lead roles one of the biggest roles and
guardians I'm gonna get him a poster of
his own movie I love you thank you for
coming here today thank you for allowing
to be inside of you again good deal
amazing interview I really I really love
talking to the guy and he's a lot of fun
I have to remind him that I've had back
surgeries because he likes to tackle me
put me in headlocks and things like that
I love going to conventions with him and
seen him there it's just a he's with
like like I am with my fans very
affectionate and loud and fun and vocal
he is that way and so we have a lot of
fun together and like we meet up with
Sean Gunn my good buddy Sean all right
let's get a shout out real quick to the
top tier patrons before that I'd like to
tell you that hopefully if this is all
good by October 12 July 2nd remember
austin north door back to back live
podcast inside of you Zach Levi's the
guest hopefully that continues that will
be
I second if all said and done always
well and then so much else I mean
there's a lot of conventions if those
come back later in the year and what
else I wanted to I want to share with
you oh I'm still planning on doing camp
Rosie I know I've said it there's no
links out there but there's not gonna be
many tickets but it's Halloween week in
October 30th October 31st those two
nights it's like you're at summer camp
you are at summer camp but you're an
adult and there's uh costumes at night
costume parties we have a Halloween one
of course we have 80s we have a DJ we're
gonna have it's all you could drink all
you can eat for the week including free
stuff healthy stuff along with kickball
dodgeball capture the flag all that
stuff it's gonna be so much fun my
friends will be there so make sure you
you're on top of it and check with my
social media and listen to the podcast
and because that once that link goes up
you know there's only gonna be like 150
tickets and I guarantee fifty am I gonna
be my friends and another 50 gonna be my
patrons and the other 50 are you I don't
know who I was doing right there Macho
Man Savage here are the top tier patrons
I couldn't do this show without them
because right now they're soo they're
they're supplying the goods there there
amidst this tough time
you like the word amidst but they're uh
they're pledging money they're helping
out the podcast their choice and they've
decided to do that which is wonderful so
I appreciate that so check out patreon
if you haven't here we go
Allison L Andrew see Angelina G Barry I
Barry I you've been around I always F
your name up cuz I see this one line I
it's I it's Barry I if it's not you're
gonna hate me Olson I see deleted patron
Barry I or barielle Bob be Bob are bull
decks Brian age Chris see JP Emily k
Emily s Hamza be Jake M Jason D Jason W
Jennifer s hi Jennifer house Jerry wjr a
Jilly Joshua D Catherine M Kevin R
Kimberly E
Lauren G
leah ass Orly whatever you want sister
Christian Marc a Milus are Mikey Nancy D
Neil W Nico P Raj I got to talk to Raj
and Instagram live he's got more toys
than I do REME i'll ream you out man
Robert Robert be old Robert be samantha
em Sarah V Stacey B tabatha t Anna
Trisha Vanessa in the sky and yours
truly everybody
Yukiko I love you Kiko what am i doing
you know what else I'm doing if you go
and zoom they have this thing where you
can share this screen and I like to all
my friends show them an old my favorite
clip from SNL they could show me funny
stuff and we kind of share it and by the
way tweet me Instagram you any movies or
documentaries I should watch har I like
car but I probably seen it all there's a
movie I saw called the the platforms you
guys see that platform really good on
Netflix it's so it's free if you have
Netflix oh I guess you're paying the
monthly but anyway I can't I can't thank
you guys enough for the support you
given me for this podcast and anything
you could do remember the podcast is
free so anything you could do if you're
enjoying it you get something out of it
these guests open up they talk about
their anxieties their depressions all
these things that are so important I'm
gonna try and get some health people on
here and what do you guys think I'm
gonna have to zoom some guest soon if
this keeps going because I have a couple
more guests in the in the can as they
call it but what do you think would you
still watch it if it was on Zoom if it
me it would be on this still in the
YouTube channel and Spotify but I'd have
to zoom some guests but I get the matter
you listen the jensen ackles
he was on there so there you have it but
i love all the support thank you so much
and a big shout out to a random shout
out to Brandi Edie who does all my merch
I think I'm wearing it right now yeah
left on Laurel hat she she made the Hat
she makes a lot of the shirts she does a
lot of stuff and I couldn't do without
her it's the inside of you online store
you can get left on Laurel merch and
inside of you merch we're coming up with
new t-shirts too that I'm designing or
I'm having this guy design if you like
the blue ones we're trying to do
something different
again I don't know what to say thank you
for the support I love you all keep
tuning in please tell your friends force
them to watch it grab their phone
subscribe you know got to keep this
going man
I really love it and I hope you do so
thank you for allowing me to get inside
all of you and I miss Ryan I miss I'm
sitting here right now if you can see it
it's just just a pair of cans that
didn't sound right it's a set of cans
that didn't sound right either it is a
it's headphones that are resting on this
couch so get over it that's about it I
love you so much thank you
I mean it be safe be healthy be happy
laugh be busy exercise all right I'm
[ __ ] mother [ __ ] off now thanks
[Music]